hello everyone and welcome today
to today's live broadcast vitamin b6
addiction in acute myeloid leukemia my
name is mark garner from
agilent and i'll be the moderate
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by lab roots
and is sponsored by agilent for more
information
please visit our website at agilent.com
so uh now let's get started uh i'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time during the presentation to
do so simply
type them in the ask a question box you
see on your screen
and click the send button if you have
any trouble
hearing or seeing the presentation you
can click on the support tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
i'd now like to introduce our presenter
dr justin
cross who's director of the donald b and
catherine c
marin cancer metabolism center for a
complete biography of dr
cross you can visit please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen dr cross you
may now begin the presentation
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
this lab boots presentation thank you
for making the time to listen to some of
our recent work
aimed at understanding metabolic
vulnerabilities in cancer
these are my disclosures none of these
are related to this presentation
so over the next 40 minutes or so i
wanted to talk you through
some of our recent work focused on
understanding how metabolic processes
can become vulnerabilities in particular
cancer types or disease settings
a tremendous amount of work has taken
place over the last 10 to 15 years
attempting to understand how metabolic
processes
are subverted by cancer cells i'm going
to
highlight how this how far this field
has come in the past decade and some
vulnerabilities that have been
identified and exploited as approved
cancer therapies
i'm then going to introduce a crispr
cast 9 screen that we performed
aimed at identifying novel
vulnerabilities in acute myeloid
leukemia
cells i will show you how a pdx
helped pdxk which is an enzyme that's
central to the vitamin d6 metabolism
pathway
was identified as a specific metabolic
vulnerability in leukemia cells
and the word campus ending is a
collaboration between my group
scott lowe's laboratory and memorial
sloan kettering and lingbo zhang's group
at cold spring harvard laboratory
i'll show you some follow-up experiments
that show the effect
that pdxk deletion has on a range of
cell types
and how we leverage metabolic profiling
and stable isotope tracing
to characterize the full impact of pdxk
deletion
on the cellular metabolum and how
metabolic ltms based metabolic profiling
can reveal
unexpected changes and
interestingly there are already several
drugs available that target b6
metabolism
in other settings so we use these drugs
as tool compounds and i'll show you
their impact on cellular metabolism in
vitro
and end by showing you how they can
impact
the growth of leukemic cells in the evil
mouse models
so i'm going to start by introducing the
field of cancer metabolism
because almost all cancers display
alterations in cellular metabolism
but whether this metabolic reprogramming
is a cause or a consequence of a cancer
phenotype has remained a topic of debate
there are several general metabolic
changes that have been exploited by
therapies in the last few years so for
example
asparaginase which is an enzyme which is
given as a treatment for childhood lymph
acute lymphoblastic
lymphoma and non-hodgkin's lymphoma
and and an enzyme inhibitor of the
dihydroauratese um protein in in
pyrimidine biosynthesis
are both examples of enzymes or
therapies which
target a process that is present in all
cells but there seems to be a
therapeutic window to giving those
inhibitors and targeting that pathway in
cancer cells
there are other examples where a
specific metabolic gene
is mutated and that leads to a
targetable opportunity so examples of
that
isocitrate dehydrogenase and succinate
dehydrogenase these are
enzymes in the tca cycle where a
mutation causes a specific change
and an alteration in the cancer cell
which can then be exploited for
therapies
so that differs slightly because it's
because it's a targeted change versus
the general metabolic process present in
all cells
that can be inhibited and give a
selective therapeutic window in cancer
cells
so we began the process of looking for
other
metabolic vulnerabilities in cancer
cells by conducting a genetic screen in
leukemia cells
so i'm going to quickly introduce how we
conduct these screens so the basic
concept
is a crispr cast 9
library is introduced into a into
cells and then a competition screen is
done to see which
of those guide rnas are are enriched and
which are lost
in in a in a population that grows out
from the screen
so when those guys in the pot in the
resulting population are sequenced
we get a output something like this
where you see that some guides target
genes where the um which are depleted in
the screen
so those target those are targeting
genes which are essential to the growth
of the cells
and and they are the the guide is
depleted from the sequencing results
because the leukemia cells that get that
guy don't proliferate
and there are other other genes which
are enriched in the screen so those are
crispr guides that are targeting genes
which are
which their deletion improves the growth
of leukemia cells
so in this work we um we decided to make
a a crispr gene library which was a
which was covering a subset of metabolic
genes of interest
so we considered a large number of genes
annotated to have metabolic roles
and compared them to genes which were
enriched in leukemia cells
and that led to an overlap of 236 genes
that you can see there highlighted in
the middle
which are both metabolic annotated as
metabolic
and enriched in leukemia and so that was
the library of guides that was made
and used to infect a leaky a mouse model
of leukemia in vitro and the results the
sequencing results similar to the
cartoon i just showed you but these are
now the actual sequencing results from
this screen as shown below
and you can see that known tumor
suppressors like p53
are enriched so knocking out that gene
deleting that gene
improve improves the growth of the cells
and a number of genes that are known as
to be drivers of leukemia such as bcl2
ncl1 rpa1 is an essential gene
all of these genes are depleted from the
screen because knocking those genes out
impairs
the viability of the leukemia cells
importantly there's also a several
non-targeting
genes team guides vanilla is is the one
that's highlighted there
that were neither depleted nor enriched
in the screen
and then i'm highlighting the pdxk gene
so this is the
this will be the subject of this talk
and um pdxk is
an important enzyme in in v6 metabolism
and surprisingly multiple guides against
pdxk
were also depleted in the screen
so in prioritizing which genes to follow
up from the hits
pdxk was selected as interesting because
of this reason so this is a
is a composite of many different non-aml
and aml
um gene expression arrays and you see
that that pdxk is actually
an enriched gene gene expression in in
aml
cells and and other systems
along with the bcl-2 a validated driver
of aml
so we took a little closer look at this
uh a pdx cave um and and i just want to
introduce where this sits in vitamin d6
metabolism
so um to orientate you
in in in this in this metabolic pathway
there are actually six important
compounds here so
uh vitamin b6 is the collective term for
all six of these
and um pyridoxine pyridoxal and
pyridoxamine on the left
and their phosphorylated forms all form
part of this network
and you can see on the right that the ax
in extras in the extracellular space
this could be tissue culture media
or or the serum in vivo um the
free form of the of the of the b6
species is the non-phosphorylated form
um it's imported into the cytosol and
then it gets phosphorylated and that's
the role pdxk plays it phosphorylates
the b6 to capture it and sequester it
and then both pnp and pmp can be
converted into plp
by the action of pnpo
there's also a phosphatase which which
works in opposition to pdxk
so to validate hits from the screen the
next thing we did was to take
individual crispr guides and subject
them to competition assays
so in these experiments um viruses are
made with each guide individually
and in use to infect a target population
and the guide also contains a gfp so
that the cells that get the guide are
marked with fluorescent
gfp um the competition assay starts by
following the percentage of cells
that are gfp green and then watching
whether they are enriched or depleted
over the course of several days in
culture
so this is an example of the follow-up
essay for pdxk
and you can see here that guides
targeting three different
um three different guides against pdxk
are depleted over the course of 14 days
in culture whereas guide's a
non-targeting guide
rosa 26 control is not so this
validates pdxk as required for these
the proliferation of this um nras
mll af9 fusion leukemia
so um the the the reason why we really
um decided to focus on pdxk was not
because it was the only metabolic hit in
the screen but because of this
interesting follow-up experiment
so i've kept the the um nras
model of leukemia on the right and we're
going to refer to that sometimes as rn2
as a shorthand for that for that
leukemia model during this presentation
but then on the left
are immortalized meth cells mouse
embryonic fibroblasts
subjected to the same competition assay
and you can see that mast cells
surprisingly
were not affected by the deletion of
pdxk
so three different guides the same three
guides and
in a similar competition assay they are
not depleted over the course of
14 days in culture and the last gene
rpa rpa3 is is an essential gene
just as a positive control to show that
the assay is working in the mast cells
so this became more interesting when we
also
looked in in several mouth leukemia
models so
on the left here we're looking at the
same tdx cage as gene disruption
in a variety of mouse uh leukemia cell
models so
nll af9 is the one that we've with nras
is the one we've already looked at at
the top
but then there are four additional um
well
commonly described mouse models of
leukemia and you can see that pdxk
is also deleted in those deletion in
those models
also results in a loss of cell viability
over two weeks
and and this also applied to two
commonly used leukemia cell lines in
vitro so
you see over this time over 30 days in
culture
that pdxk deletion um
leads to a loss of viability and also a
loss
of the gf and zero loss of the gfp mount
cells
over 30 days in culture
so pdxk appears to be an important gene
of important metabolic gene
um for for the growth of leukemia cells
in culture but the next
validation experiment was to see what
happened when we
when we suppress pdxk in vivo
so this was done both with the crispr
system which i've already described but
then here is a
second parallel experiment where we used
shrna
to suppress the expression of pdxk so
it's a similar
idea that a lentiviral vector is made
with a retroviral vector is made with
with um
with targeting pdxk marked with gfp
and and used to infect cells those cells
are introduced
into subleasely irradiated mice and
then then the the cells are followed
by um a whole body whole body imaging
and you can see here that um that the
while the control targeting cells the
vanilla cells
uh expand rapidly between day five and
day 14 and i've detected
through the whole body imaging the the
cells that have
suppression of pdxk with two different
shrnas
uh grow much less that's quantified on
the right
and that leads to a survival difference
over the course of about a month so it
appears that
pdxk is important not only for leukemia
cell growth in vitro
but also cell growth in vivo
so that's the result of deletion of the
gene
but um the next thing we wanted to do
was understand
a little more about how pdxk
actually affects the metabolic network
we expect that this
gene is involved in d6 metabolism and
we'll change v6 levels but there's
always
the chance that that metabolic genes
also have
other roles other signaling roles or
structural roles so the next
the next task was to was to examine
whether pdxk deletion
actually impacted cellular bc the
cellular b6 network
so to do this we built an lcms assay to
detect plp
um this worked for both plp in in
in plasma and in cells from mice but
also
in cell culture extracts and so here you
just see the chromatographic retention
time of the plp peak
and an internal standard and and and the
peak spiked
with um with a standard to check that um
it's it's the correct retention time
so when pdxk is deleted in
in the mouse leukemia model i've just
been describing
um with with n activated mras and the
mll af9 fusion you see that
we lose protein expression and we also
lose a substantial amount of the
plp level detected in the cell extracts
and the controls are on the right in
green
and this was actually also the case for
the
for the meth cell line and for another
um
leukemia cell line 13. now the
interesting thing here is remember the
left cell line could still proliferate
even with
um with with disruption of the ptxk gene
but the growth of the leukemia cell line
the rn2 cells on the left is inhibited
and that's shown more clearly here you
can see that over
several days in passage the mast cells
continue
to proliferate exponentially um in the
presence
oh or absence of b6 in the media
but the um that the mll
af9 cells they proliferate when
supplemented with b6
but in these sex deficient media they
their growth is slowed
so this is um if we return to the
vitamin b6 network
um and and look at the place of pdxk in
the in the network i mentioned that
that's a phosphorylation and capture
reaction for all of the
circulating forms of b6 so um
we then looked at the um we then looked
at the
uh deletion of of the other genes in the
network
um the pdx p gene the phosphate which
opposes pdxk that had no effect
and pnpo which is the enzyme which
metabolizes pnp
and pmt into plp and
that's not that did not score
in this competition assay or in the plp
levels
because the cells also have a source of
pl
circulating and in the tissue culture
media
so pl can be converted directly into plp
so pnpo is not required
um it still has an impact because in
tissue culture the main
form of pn in the main form of vitamin
b6 and cell culture media is pn
so um so a lot of the a lot goes through
the ac through pnpo but there's a path
with pl being directly converted to plp
and uh when we when we try different
media conditions
um we find that the knocking out of
pnpo has no effect in media that
has pl which is shown in the bottom
right here
but it does impact cells where the only
source of
vitamin d6 pn so that's in the middle of
the bottom
pdxk here is always shown as a control
and when we look in the same publicly
available gene expression data
you find that uh none of these other pdx
can the pdx p and p npo the two other
genes in the network are not
particularly enriched in aml cells in
the same way that pdxk was
so this point would seem to be something
specific
about the action of pdxk and the
requirement to convert
the unfortunate forms to their
phosphorylated forms that was important
for leukemia cell growth
so um the next thing we considered
is what the um what the
what the range of impacts are of a plp
in the cell
what what is plp actually being used for
so there are over 120
enzymes in the cell that are plp
dependent
the broad categories they fall into are
shown on this slide
and whilst there are genes involved in
many important metabolic cycles
on prolate metabolism and carbohydrate
metabolism lipid metabolism
are shown on the right the majority of
plp-dependent enzymes
are involved in transaminase reactions
and the metabolism of amino acids and
that group is shown on the left here
so this is where we decided we would use
uh metabolomic profiling by lcms to try
and better understand what the real
impact was of this pdxk deletion on
on the rn2 leukemia cells and why
this disruption of pdxk and what we've
seen is depletion of plp
seem to allow mast cells to still
proliferate
so one of the things we can do with an
lcms data set first of all is just take
the 10 000 foot view and and look at all
of the features in the data set and just
see what on the global level is changed
and this was reassuring because it backs
up what we're seeing in terms of
viability and growth in the pdxk
deletion actually did not perturb the
metabolism
metabolism of nest cells very much
but just a couple of metabolites scoring
there
um but in the leukemia cells the rn2
cells
there was many more metabolites which
are down regulated
and um and it was all significantly
changed and most of the significantly
changed metabolites
are down regulated so that's um
that's the untargeted view but then we
decided
to build on this observation we should
build a
metabolomic profile that's specifically
considered
the reactants and the products of
plp-dependent reactions and really try
and drill down into
how how this pdfk deletion was impacting
the global metabolism
and and specifically these reactions
that are plp dependent
so um what i've done here is highlight
the results of
several different lcms methods pulled
together with each covering a different
area of chemical space
to to bring together all of these
metabolites into a single
um into a single image and you can see
we've highlighted right there in the
middle
in blue plp which is the
gene that with pdxk disruption in both
cell lines
plp is decreased and
and we also see pl is decreased and
that's because as i mentioned the major
source
of vitamin b6 and cell culture is pn
that becomes pnp then plp
and then pl is derived from that so um
so pl
is also down so that's the positive
control right there in the middle
and in the top section we've highlighted
metabolites which are linked to amino
acid metabolism
and annotated them with the
plp-dependent reactions
so here you really see that a lot of
these
plp-dependent genes um that
the products of them are depleted and
this this depletion is specific to the
leukemia cells
nest cells seem unperturbed
i want to particularly then draw your
attention to a little further down
so that's the that's the top part with
all of the
plp dependent amino acid metabolism
going down in the leukemia cells
but if we now zoom in on the bottom part
you can see some nucleotide metabolism
and again we see
a lot of the nucleotides are depressed
in the
rn2 leukemia cells we also see decreases
in tca and cycle metabolism towards the
bottom of the heat map
um two of the strongest changes on here
are ones that we're going to come back
to in the next couple of slides so you
see carbohydric acid
that is an upstream metabolite in the
pyrimidine synthesis
pathway and that is the most depressed
metabolism
and imp is a nucleotide in purine
synthesis and that one
is elevated um the importance of imp
is that it is the purine synthesis
product which
causes feedback inhibition on the
pathway and that
that is relevant when there's a mismatch
between purine and pyrimidine synthesis
so um an increase in inp can indicate
that the purine synthesis pathway is
being held in check
because there is a problem with the
pyrimidine pathway and carbohydric acid
being down is
is a precursor of pyrimidine synthesis
this kind of pointed us towards
nucleotides since
this is an area we should spend a bit
more time
now metabolomic profiling can can get
you can only get you so far because
those pool size changes that can be hard
to interpret
because uh we don't always know whether
um
whether a pool size is increasing
because a pathway is becoming more
relevant and being upregulated or
because it is
becoming um it is the pathway is not
being used anymore and things are
accumulating
as a result of a block downstream so
absolute so levels in a profiling
experiment can be a little tricky to
interpret
but a way around that is to add
stabilized stove tracing
so i mentioned that many of the
plp-dependent reactions are involved in
amino acid metabolism and moving
nitrogen
around particularly glutamine being the
major donor of nitrogen in the cell
so a reduced nitrogen so we can use
isotopically labeled glutamine
to trace some of these plp-dependent
reactions and the advantage of adding a
stable isotope tracer in
is that we can use the lcms experiment
not only to look at the
relative rate of reactions and the but
also the source of the metabolite and
superimpose that information as we've
done here on the total pool types
so um a high level summary of this data
is basically that again you'll see that
meths on the left are less impacted than
the rn2 cells on the right
and as we look at these four plp
dependent enzymes
you also see that it is the uh flux from
the tracer
the the label glutamine which is
highlighted in the red color
that is blocked by the pdxk deletion so
that could mean there are pre-existing
pools in the cell that contribute to the
rest
and we and in long if we wait longer
more of this metabolite becomes labeled
or it might be that um there are other
sources for some of these metabolites
but
the tracing experiment helps give us
confidence that these plp-dependent
reactions are really inhibited um and
that's the result of that results in the
change in pool size
so as i mentioned we had really focused
on
surveying all of the plp-dependent
reactions that we could measure by
by lcms and and we really now started to
focus on two particular pathways and one
was the pyrimidine synthesis pathway
uh ending in uridine shown on the right
and the other one
is the polyamine synthesis pathway um on
the
on on the right um the pyrimidine
pathway on the left
so um the reason why we focused on these
two pathways is because they both start
with a important plp-dependent enzyme
that seems to be
a good candidate um so got2
is the enzyme in pyrimidine biosynthesis
and odc1
is the ornithine decarboxylase is the
enzyme in
in in polyamine biosynthesis that are
plp-dependent targets
and this was really um borne out by the
tracing data so just to go back and
highlight that particular change again
you'll see here that
utp as an as a downstream product of
got2
is is is reduced in the rn2 cells
preserved in the mast cells and and
n-acetylputriding as an example of one
of the polyamines
is reduced in both cells but more
reduced in the
rn2 cells so these are the two pathways
we really wanted to focus on
things became a little more complicated
when we looked um
at the at the when we try and take into
account the carbon aspartate result
so um got two as i mentioned
is focused on the production of
aspartate and aspartate is
important in pyrimidine biosynthesis
because it's right at the top of the
pyrimidine path
pyrimidine pathway we have this enzyme
called ammo phosphate synthetase
which react which which uses glutamine
as a nitrogen donor and and and
bicarbonate to make carbon or phosphate
and the next step is the addition of an
aspartate to make carbon aspartate
so our assumption when we saw that
pyrimidine biosynthesis
was impacted and nucleotide biosynthesis
was impacted
and and um and there was an
there was a plp dependent enzyme right
at the top of that pathway that we were
expecting to see that aspartate levels
were disrupted and that was the reason
why pyrimidine proteins would
was inhibited but surprisingly on
looking at aspartate on multiple
different lcms methods and by different
approaches
and also in this tracing experiment we
actually don't see
that the pdxk inhibition directly
disrupted the aspartate levels in the
cell
however carbonyl aspartate which is um
the metabolite uh right after
the first metabolite in the pathway we
can measure well by lcms
is disrupted in the rn2 cells by pdfk
deletion
so this remains somewhat of a puzzle
because um we've got here
an enzyme which there there is no known
plp dependent reaction
in calvary aspartate synthesis but it's
um that it seems to be the most
regulated metabolism
metabolite in the pathway and
potentially explains why pyrimidines
levels are lower overall so this is an
area that we are still
looking into um and trying to understand
why a generalized uh loss of plp in the
cell would impact this upstream step
into
pyrimidine biosynthesis um
we did notice a few things along the way
i think all of which are
observations that are a little somewhat
surprising and
um one of them is just the level of
vitamin b6 which is consumed by cells so
um we were thinking about why meth cells
were were less sensitive to this
perturbation than
rn2 cells we thought well maybe it's
something to do with the amount of the
pn they can access from the media
so we looked at the pn level which i
mentioned is the former v6 that's
that's that's provided in cell culture
media and you can see
that um that control cells actually
over the course of 24 hours actually
consume a large amount of the pn
that's available to them in the media
the pdxk knockout cells in both cases
can't access that pm
we thought about whether maybe the mess
just have a higher reserve level inside
the cell
and that's somehow how they're able to
survive the storm we didn't see
any uh increase in plp levels inside the
mass
in in the mast cells they do somehow
appear to know
that they're in problems though because
they accumulate pm
so this form of pn this form of b6 was
provided to them in the media
actually becomes accumulated in the
cells
um over the course of a 24-hour
experiment
but when when pdxk is disrupted um but
not in the rnt
cells so we don't fully understand what
that means but it does
seem to indicate the mast cells have an
awareness that the plp network is
disrupted and a sequestering pn in an
attempt to fix the problem
now maybe um and it's worth just
highlighting the catalytic reaction
mechanism that plp undergoes because
this is something where we thought we
might be able to make some progress in
understanding
how how leukemia cells are specifically
sensitive to
this change um plp the code for the
fight the
the active cofactor is shown on the top
of this slide and the
the red ring highlights an active oxygen
in the molecule
and if this oxygen that in the active
side of the enzyme
forms a covalent bridge with the amino
acid that's shown in the bottom left
and and the active side of the enzyme
stabilizes that transition state
so that's the that's the uh active
chemistry in these transaminase
reactions
so uh this actually this active
chemistry actually becomes a problem in
some particular situations
so in in inborn areas of metabolism
there are two
uh inborn eras that are known to produce
high levels of a product
this is this is one in protein
metabolism which produces
p5c shown on the left and the other one
is a is
it is um and antiquidin is an enzyme in
lysine metabolism and mutations in that
enzyme result in
accumulation of p6c now you can see that
both of these
molecules have a similar structure and
these actually will react
with plp and sequester plp
and titrate it away so this leads to
a secondary plp deficiency in these
diseases
because plp is being titrated by a
metabolite which is accumulating and
then reacting away the plp
and those and actually in the case of
the lysine metabolism
disorder it results in an epilepsy that
is treated by high levels of plp
administration
so we wondered if there was something
similar happening in the rn2 cells and
we spent a lot of time tracing
with with labeled pn to try and find and
to try and find if there was something
in the leukemia cells that was titrating
away the
plp and making them more susceptible to
the deletion
um and that that ended up being a dead
end we didn't find anything like this
happening in the cells
so um the next thing we did was really
just
turn to a pharmacological strategy
and this works out because there are
actually two existing drugs
which um which target pdxk
and vitamin b6 metabolism but by very
different mechanisms
so the first one uh 5-methylpro
pyridoxine at the top is also called
toxin it's the
toxin produced by gingko trees and um
you see that has a very similar
structure to pyridoxine and that's
actually a competitive inhibitor
against pdxk the other
uh drug on this slide isoniazid is a
drug that has been used
in treating tb and um and
that has a very similar structure if i
just go back one
to the uh p5p
p5c and p6c that we just highlighted
here can react with plp
and that's exactly how that drug that
drive works it it sequesters plp in a
similar
mechanism so we just described with the
inborn errors
um and and and titrates away plp
so we can actually see that happening in
in cell culture experiments um we
if we add isoniazide to cells in culture
and look at their plp levels i'm going
to walk you through this slide starting
with the graph on the right
when we measure plp we add a labeled
internal standard to the extraction
solvent to normalize the measurement
and the graph on the top right is the d3
label the deuterated plp internal
standard
and you can see that if we don't wash
the cells
then we lose the internal standard that
the green does
so that means that the uh that the
isoniazide is actually able to react
with our plp internal standard which
means there's enough residual pns
in the sample that there's a post
there's a there's an in vitro reaction
just in the preparation of the sample
that titrates away the plp and if we
wash the cells first
we get rid of that isoniazide from the
cell culture and now the plp
internal standard remains intact in the
blue
so a similar thing is actually happening
in the cells and so if you look at the
plp levels in the cells
now moving to the top left in the green
bars we see
that there is a large decrease as we
increase the isoniazid concentration we
lose plp
but the problem is that's a post-lysis
reaction just the same as we reacted to
their internal standard
we actually have to watch the cells to
reveal the true decrease
in plp interestedly which is more modest
but still there so that's the blue bars
on the top
left and we can because we have a full
scan mass spec we can follow the
production of that isonialite plp
product and that's shown in the bottom
graphs that when when we have high
levels of plp present and high levels of
isolite we form that product
so isoniazid is able to to decrease
the interest of the plp level to about
50 percent over the time course of this
assay
and so we next went back to those
targeted metabolomics experiments to see
what the impact was on the cellular
metabolism
so here you see that several of the same
metabolites
um the the effects are reproduced um
similar to the
to the to the gene disruption with
crispr um
if we focus on isoniazide there are
metabolites which are decreased
and some more modestly like acidops and
acetopugenine and histamine
but then that's the that's the that's
the drug that
forms the um covalent
reaction with plp but the drug that's a
competitive inhibitor
of pdxk is actually more effective and
you see that for example histamine and
acetyl putrazine
the levels are really decreased by that
drug so that's active um
similar phenocopying the pdsk disruption
interestingly aspartate which was that
metabolite that we really thought
would be the reason why the pyrimidine
pathway was in was disrupted
is not decreased if anything it's
increased
um we see the increase in imp with the
gingka toxin
um so again indicating that it's not the
the loss of the nucleotide pools is not
it's not likely to be due to the purines
the purines are feedback inhibited and
we have a loss of pyrimidines
um and again not because of aspartate
but because of this
this loss of carbohydrate and here again
we see complete loss of carbohydrates
so this um remains a little bit of a
puzzle
um as to why pyrimidine biosynthesis is
so
impacted at this upstream level where
there are no obvious
plp-dependent enzymes we are looking at
other reasons why pyrimidine and this
step might be disrupted there's
there's a possibility it's it's
signaling
that nitrogen handling and glutamine
pools in the cell are disrupted
and looking at other ways in which that
cps one enzyme
upstream of kapamya asparage is being
regulated
but nevertheless pyrimidine biosynthesis
seems to be
the place that leukemia cells are most
impacted
and it's perhaps not surprising that the
leukemia model
comes down to a defect in nucleotide
metabolism
because these cells are growing
extremely fast
so the nest cells have a cell volume
on a cooler counter of about 1400
centiliters
whereas the rn2 leukemia cells have a
volume more like 700 femtoliters
so they're much smaller but they still
have a full genome and they're also
growing much faster so the things that
the leukemia cells have to do
much faster than a meth cell both
because
on a per cell basis they just have more
nucleotides to make to replicate their
genome
so we believe that that the pdxk
susceptibility of leukemia cells is due
to the nucleotide metabolism
it's just this unexpected disruption of
pyrimidine metabolism
and and that's reinforced by this
experiment where we add just
add 30 micromolar uridine which is the
end the first
pyrimidine product in that pathway and
that can rescue
um the growth of of these leukemia cells
so the
so the pdxk cells are now able to
compete in a
in and expand um with uridine
supplementation
so to end i just wanted to go through
some avivo experiments to actually try
and determine whether any of this
any of this biology related to b6
metabolism
would play out in an in vivo model of
leukemia
so to do this we return to this mouse
model of leukemia
where we can inject the cells into
sublethally irradiated mice
and then administer ted tool compounds
to see if we can slow the growth of
leukemia cells in vivo
so in this case we are now treating with
isoniazide
and this was with daily doses of 40 migs
per kilogram isolite
isoniazide and you can see that over
a two or three week period the
growth of the leukemia cells in two
different models is slowed
um and the whole body imaging shows is
quantified in the middle
and this translates into a survival
advantage for the
um mice receiving the itemized
um this data was recently published in a
in a
paper um in cancer cell earlier this
year
and um and here's the um
here's the plp measurement showing that
isoniazide
uh was the decrease the plp levels in
both bone marrow cells
and in the plasma and um and then we
went on to test whether
whether isoniazide could synergize with
um with a with a previously validated
uh leukemia drug abt-199 which targets
bcl-2
and you can see that there is evidence
of synergy um shown in the darker green
color as you increase the levels of both
isoniazide
and the avid compound the um the the
inhibition of of the leukemia cell
growth in vivo
is and in vitro is his additive
oh also and and moves towards
synergistic
so um the last experiment that we tried
was to see whether just instead of using
a pharmacological intervention
lowering the b6 levels through the diet
would be effective in slowing leukemia
growth so
we get most of our b6 from from dietary
sources from plants
and um and in mouse chow it's actually
supplemented to quite high levels
so you can get a b6 deficient mouse diet
by
by ordering the diet without the
supplement
and um and here you show here we
show that the plp level is
is decreased in mice once we give that
diet
for two weeks and and you can see that
that also has some effect in slowing the
growth
of the leukemia cells in vivo that the
mice don't lose weight
on the diet shown on the bite
so with that i'd like to just summarize
and
and and show that we think that this
work has revealed another metabolic
vulnerability in cancer cells
and the pdft seems to be a
leukemia-specific metabolic dependency
so it's a fundamental metabolic process
in all cells but there seems to be a
therapeutic window
that inhibition of the of the b6
metabolism pathway through pdxk really
slows the growth of leukemia cells but
not a range
of of untransformed non-leukemia cells
we've shown how the the impact of pdxk
deletion really does impact the global
metabolism of leukemia cells
but we see a particular disruption
of a lot of plp-dependent enzymes
and of these enzymes we feel like the
the pyrimidine pathway is probably the
place that is most impacting the cell
growth and we use tracing experiments
and lcms profiling
to show that that the purine pathways
inhibited with
imp levels and the pure pyrimidine
pathways
appear to be um inhibited with that
upstream
intermediate being decreased albumin
aspartate
i showed you two existing drugs one is
an allosteric
one is a one is a competitive drug and
one is a what is a
is a drug that binds plp
covalently um both of which can be used
to inhibit
inhibit a plp-dependent enzymes
in vitro and isoniazide one of those
enzymes
slows leukemia progression in mouse
models
so with that i'd like to stop and thank
everybody who was involved in this work
on the left is my group and also this is
a collaboration with scott lowe's lab
and lingbo zhang's lab i particularly
want to point out
chi chao chen a graduate student in
scotland's lab that started this work
he's now at agile pharmaceuticals
and bully um in limbo's lab
who did a vlog for this work and then
sarah we
and willa in my group um and
with that i would like to garnish the
funding sources
and thank everybody for their attention
and i'd be delighted to take any
questions and i'm going to leave you
with a picture of my group appropriate
for the times
how we now all end up meeting each other
socially
so thank you
okay
thank you dr cross for that very
informative uh presentation
uh we'll now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
again if you have a question you'd like
to ask please do so
now click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay so to get started
the first question
is um your global metabolomics profiling
indicated a general defect
in mitochondrial nitrogen handling have
you looked to see if glutamine analysis
is different in the absence of pdxk
that's a that's actually a really good
point we haven't checked
glutaminolysis and glutamine handling
specifically beyond the tracing
experiments but an easy way to address
that would be
to look at the consumption of glutamine
from the cell culture media and that's
something we're currently
trying there's also um
[Music]
another good way i guess to evaluate
overall mitochondrial function is with a
seahorse experiment because oxygen
consumption is generally viewed as
the the total output of the mitochondria
basically is summed up in that oxygen
consumption measurement so that's
something we'd also like to do is
is um is to look for the seahorse
profile of the meth and the leukemia
cells
um with the pdxk deletion
mark are you still there i think i see
there's one more
i'm sorry a recent paper showed that
cps1 is important for pyrimidine
synthesis
in a lung cancer you showed pyrimidine
synthesis came through the cps2
cytosolic pyrimidine pathway but have
you considered a role for cps one
yeah that's a that's also an interesting
point that's work from ralph to
beradinus's lab who showed a couple of
years ago that um
the um the mitochondrial carbamal
phosphate synthesis pathway is important
that's typically
known as part of the urea cycle a way of
excreting ammonium
from the from the mitochondria but it's
um he showed in lung cancer that that
pathway was involved in pyrimidine
biosynthesis so we did consider that we
tried supplementing cells with ammonium
chloride to see if we could rescue
the leukemia cells up with the pdxk
deletion
that didn't work in fact if anything
adding ammonia is toxic to those cells
um we have tried tracing ammonium
chloride but again it wasn't
very informative because the addition of
ammonia doesn't benefit those cells
[Music]
the in the older literature there's
actually um some work
on using various inhibitors to try and
dissect the role of cps1 and cps2 in
hepatic metabolism
um so we're actually thinking about
using those
compounds we're just interested in
trying to look at the allosteric
regulators and inhibitors of both of
those cps pathways and try and identify
which one is more important but at the
moment we're leading towards the
cytosolic pathway is the mind from one
of
okay okay excellent um we do have time
for
just a few more questions i want to
remind everyone in the audience that
questions were unable to answer today
and those that come in
during the on-demand period will be
answered by the speaker
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
um we have one other question in
uh you showed global metabolomics
profiling of cells
in vitro response to pdxk deletion
but how does this compare to human
studies of b6 deficient patients
well that's a that's an interesting
point because um there are actually
several metabolomic profiles already out
there for
um in various contexts from humans
patients that uh
that have pl have vitamin d6 deficient
diets
um it's also been studied in the context
of those um
secondary deficiencies i mentioned in
the inborn areas of metabolism
um so i mean
it's not exactly analogous what happens
in the cells and what happens in serum
because
you know the serum profiles that are
published are kind of the composite
picture
of all of the tissues in the animal and
the the
each one has different a different
spectrum of the plp-dependent enzymes
expressed and um each of those
enzymes have a different affinity for
plp so it's a complex picture
but um i we were actually pretty
encouraged by the fact that the selden
culture showed quite a lot of overlap
with some of those metabolomic studies
so
um to the spring to mind is the serine
and glycine changes those are those two
enzymes in that pathway
um psat and shmt those two enzymes are
and show up in the the impact of those
enzymes being inhibited
shows up in global serum metabolomics
and um and it also shows up clearly in
the cells and the same with
the cbs pathway so that's homocysteine
and cystocyanus
the two um are the two metabolites that
we can measure that
read out on cps activity cvs activity so
um
you know i mean the the the other thing
that i should maybe mention there is
that in
in the context of a whole organism study
the
metabolomics is often tells a clearer
story in the csf like a lot of those
studies
have focused on csf primarily because um
the the serum levels can also be
impacted by diet so as soon as you move
into the whole organism context you know
the diet
dietary source of vitamin b6 becomes a
big factor
you know like fasted animals or fasted
humans is probably the most actual way
to
to make that comparison but yeah there's
a lot of overlap between the in vitro
and the and the human in vivo picture
okay excellent
well i don't see any other questions so
uh
thank you again for the presentation dr
cross do you have any final comments for
the audience
no you're welcome but i've and the um my
email address is is
on the last slide and um i'm more than
happy to answer any questions if people
want to email me directly
okay thank you uh before we go i want to
thank the audience as well for joining
us today and for the questions
uh any questions we did not have time
for today
or those that come in on the on demand
period will be addressed
uh by the speaker by the contact
information you provided when you're
registered
uh we'd like to thank once again dr
cross for his time and his important
research i'd like to thank uh lab roots
and
our agilent for sponsor for underwriting
today's educational webcast you can view
the webinar on demand
lab routes will alert you by email when
it's available
that's all for now until next time
goodbye
you